so with everything coming out of Comic
Con and the fact that I know I'm not
going to get to all of it especially
because I you know I've actually got
plans for today but I figured I wasn't
really going to get a chance to talk
about Marvel and their TV stuff but you
know what this is my channel I can talk
about it even if there isn't a lot of
that coming out comic-con
so Marvel TV stuff we've had a couple of
things happen we gotten a new trailer
for the Inhumans we got a new trailer
for the defenders have we got a little
bit of word on Iron Fist going forward
as its own solo series so let's start
with the defenders it is another good
trailer it reinforces a lot of what I
liked about the first trailer I really
like given how much I severely disliked
Iron Fist
I really liked that pretty much all the
other characters aren't taking him
seriously and are kind of like what is
your deal dude and I'm totally down for
that because if there's a character who
needs to get dressed down a lot it's
Danny Rand we get a little glimpse of
Madame galin looks like she is scared of
Sigourney Weaver and given how much I
already like Madame Gao that is up I'm
down for that we see a lecture so we
know she's factoring into this that
makes me slightly nervous because I
didn't love the Elektra as part of the
second season of daredevil but you know
what maybe they found a better way the
user and again they show her against
Sigourney Weaver and we get a lot of
voiceover from Sigourney Weaver she more
than but there's basically two things
going to this and I'm like okay that is
sold me one is her the other is that
hallway fight they keep showing you're
close to them like that looks so good if
that can be the standard the benchmark
of the action scenes in this this is
going to be a real good time so there's
not a lot there that we didn't already
know now I want to talk about the
Inhumans trailer because I didn't do a
video talking about the first Inhumans
trailer I talked about it on one of my
podcasts but I know the the listenership
is way lower than the viewers that I get
on here so I assume none of you heard it
but yeah this looks bad like the one
thing that I like I in love I love that
they're doing lockjaw I mean just
flat-out I have loved Bulldogs I mean I
do I used to have one
and it's like that's an that's a real
quick way to my heart is putting a
bulldog up on screen so yeah I love
lockjaw we don't I wish I wish the show
was just called lockjaw and we just
follow this giant teleporting dog that
would be my favorite show ever but it's
not going to be that and unfortunately
what it looks like it is going to be
does not look good so what I'm going to
talk about here is probably going to
mash up things from the first and second
tray of it because the second the second
one was this thing's chance to go sorry
we made a bad first impression here's a
better glimpse at it which is possible
the latest Justice League trailer has
put a much better impression on me
following a very lousy first impression
so you know I'm willing to give a second
trailer a shot if I haven't been sold
yet but this thing just reinforced
everything I didn't like about the first
trailer something that I would have
liked under other circumstances I
suppose the guy who plays Ramsay Bolton
I'm not going to try and pronounce the
name I'll put it down here because they
just know I'm going to I'm going to
screw it up so I'm just going to refer
to them as Ramsay apologies he's a good
actor he deserves for me to know his
name but I'm a loser like that so he is
basically just doing Diet Ramsay here I
mean it seems very obvious they brought
him in to go hey remember that character
Ramsay Bolton that you did on Game of
Thrones it was such a wonderfully
hateable villain do that again but
here's the thing that was on HBO this is
on ABC this is going to be the pg-13 at
best version of Ramsay and I've already
gotten uncut Ramsay I don't need this
watered-down version so I immediately
lose interest in him as a villain Medusa
looks awful I mean she looks
surprisingly comic accurate with the
hair and they kept their colour scheme
and I wish I could find that admirable
but it looks in such a way that it
reminds me why like back in the 2000s
with that first x-men movie why they put
all the x-men of black leather and they
were scared to death of depicting the
costumes as comic Agger because it can
look like that but here's the big that
here's what really has shut down my
interest in this and that's this guy
that got playing Black Bolt him
no matter I can't pronounce his name I
can't even be bothered to remember his
name he leaves absolutely no impression
on me what so ever he just comes across
like a vacuum of charisma like a black
hole a just any interest I have just get
absorbed and sucked in it's gone
whenever he's gone scream I think this
really emphasizes why even though
structurally I can I can envision the
Inhumans as the TV show movies was
probably a better idea because to be
blunt about it when you're casting a TV
show especially a network show which has
a very rigorous schedule usually 20-plus
episodes it's hard to get previously
undiscovered high-level talent that's
going to pull off what you need your
lead characters to pull off and when
this was originally being pitched for
film they honestly they would have had a
better pick because the kinds of actors
who can exhibit a lot of charisma and oh
and your regal miss without speaking and
can bring all that across with just
looks and majest their eyes that's a
fairly short list and most of the actors
of that caliber who aren't already
undiscovered tend to work in movies so
when this guy moved to TV and the pool
shrunk for who they could get this guy
oh boy like you know it was the rumor
for a while oh I think they do bindis go
cuz would it be funny if you know a
character who we don't see him he just
speaks and he only says one thing but
then the one time we see him he never
talks like and honestly then you could
actually pull this part off in terms of
just looking intense and looking um you
know like like somebody to be afraid of
just with the way he can look he can do
that this guy cannot and what's more he
seems to be tried to compensate for the
fact that he's basically not allowed to
speak by really almost doing pantomime I
mean this he can't just stand there look
kind of severe yes sir and like even
exaggerated like the times he opens his
mouth that oh yeah this yeah it's not
good at all and he has to work
he's so theoretically the lead I mean I
suppose if he really doesn't sell they
can
get to the lead is as the thing goes on
but Wow like very really nothing about
these trailers impressed me but he
really who I have no interest in this
show right now so the one last thing I
want to talk about with Marvel related
TV stuff Iron Fist season 2 is getting a
new showrunner which is good because the
first season was crap but it's also bad
because it means we get more seasons
devoted to Iron Fist and as bad as the
writing and the plotting and the
dialogue and all that stuff was that was
not the only problem a big part of the
problem is pinned at Danny Rand and
again I'm not saying Finn Jones is a bad
actor but I wanted to slap him the
entire time part of that is the writing
but part of that's the performance and
if we're stuck with him as that
character boy they're gonna have to do a
lot of work to mate to bring me back on
board because even if the writing is
better if I hate the lead character
there's only so much better that this
thing could get and it has been my hope
that in the wake of the reception of
Iron Fist that he wouldn't get a flat
out second season and they just shipped
him to you know showing up in the
defenders being a supporting role in
Luke Cage and basically do Heroes for
Hire
that that would have been very strongly
my preference I don't want to spend more
time with just him and it really doesn't
do much for my enthusiasm because I
don't know who this new guy is who
they're bringing to do the second season
of iron fist
I guess he worked on heroes reborn and I
mean he's working on stuff I haven't
seen so maybe he's good but I don't know
I have nothing to base that on but I
mean I'm glad to get rid of skub oh crap
how did I not make that connection scoff
but they didn't get rid of Scott but
they moved him are they in humans oh god
now I really have no interest in that
show what but what the reception iron
first got why would you keep employing
this guy I mean props are you getting
him off the the franchise that he
effectively destroyed but why would you
move him on to your new show that really
is questionable its existence of the
firt all
God well that's a depressing connection
that I had not quite made in my hand I
think my brain was just rejecting the
possibility that this guy was continuing
to work on Marvel TV ah so that's my
thought on the current state of what we
know about what's coming down the pike
for Marvel television related stuff
still pumped from the defenders iron
fist can jump off a freaking cliff and
zero interest in the Inhumans so that's
where I am on those particular things
what are your thoughts on all this or
what comic-con stuff you wish I was
talking about that I'm just not that I
have bumped instead talk about this
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down to comment let's talk
about it don't forget to like subscribe
check me out on Twitter at council of
geeks give a listen to the council geese
podcast available on iTunes and stitcher
I am also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast also available on iTunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]